you are watching cold piston TV hi and
welcome to another cold fusion video to
go go hear the microsoft hololens has
been causing a bit of a frenzy ever
since its announcement some call it a
revolution and others call it the future
of computing Microsoft hopes that the
holographic gadget becomes the next big
computing platform with applications
ranging from video games to design to
education and architecture a couple of
weeks ago Microsoft released some more
details about the technology and allowed
some press to get their hands on the
device this allows us to gain some extra
insight in this video we'll break down
exactly what the hololens is where it
came from the reality of what it can
actually do this the hype and the
implications for the world let's get
started
so the most fundamental thing to
understand here is that the microsoft
hololens is a headset that belongs to a
technology called augmented reality in a
video I made a few years ago I covered
augmented reality at length the video is
titled augmented reality is the future
so you can check that out if you want
it'll be the first link in the
description below
to summarize augmented reality is a
parallel altered reality facilitated by
technology in this reality digital
objects menus and other data can be
added seamlessly into the users field of
view this is different from virtual
reality where the users entire reality
is substituted for a digital one to make
sure we're clear if you put on a virtual
reality device ideally your brain will
think you're in an alternate reality
somewhere else but on the other hand if
you put on an augmented reality headset
you can still see the world around you
but it's enhanced and overlaid with
digital extras so let's look at the
hololens origins where did it actually
come from what many people don't realize
is that the hololens has been in the
works for seven years it was actually
the brainchild of Microsoft employee
Alex kipman he's been working on a pair
of holographic goggles for 5 years and
before that he was working on the Kinect
which was the grandfather of the
hololens so many of you have already
seen Microsoft demo videos of people
doing incredible things with the
hololens but as expected early reports
are suggesting that it's not all that
you would imagine from the videos but it
is still very impressive so what can the
hololens actually do first off the bat
Microsoft still hasn't released all the
specific details but here's what we do
know obvious applications for the
hololens include content consumption and
communication these can be things such
as floating videos or a more immersive
skype session but this isn't on the
hololens headset can actually scan
environment in real time and do things
such as aid in the guidance of robots or
create on-the-fly semi accurate wire
meshes of objects that exist in real
life
digital objects can also interact with
their real environment for example if
you throw a ball at the floor it would
bounce around just like you would expect
all of this is possible thanks to
multiple cameras stationed inside the
headset apparently hololens also handles
sound incredibly well this is done
through the Unity engine where
developers can pin audio to specific
objects then as people wearing the
hololens walk through a specific area
the sound changes based on your
proximity to the objects just like it
would in a real world and reports say
it's good enough to trick your brain the
audio is actually delivered through two
small speakers in the headset not
headphones this is so you can still hear
the real environment around you further
to this this full windows10 integration
so when wearing a headset you can drag
items from a PC desktop and pull them
off the screen into the air and still
control them with your mouse voice
inputs are also very well done
voice commands those seemingly are
infinite so the developers can register
commands you Caleb I made my app respond
to Hello Toledo and I like pie
it's a hold of button to activate no
it's all ambient they were really
adamant about that you don't have to do
an address command like Alexa or hey
Siri or okay Google you just talk to it
and it picks it up words did you feel
like it was something being processed in
the headset or it was over Wi-Fi I would
be shocked if it wasn't in the headset
very fast enough to be an answer I mean
the response time was hello Toledo boom
Nile Oh Toledo tick tick tick boom okay
so that's a bit about what hololens can
do how does it work well as described
earlier a lot of what hololens is
capable of is made possible by an array
of cameras and sensors these include
more than five cameras accelerometers
and gyroscopes to sense where headers
and house positioned at all times in
addition to the hololens mapping out
your real world environment I would
imagine combining these data inputs
would create a pretty compelling
experience so that's pretty cool but
let's get a bit deeper into the guts
according to its creator Alex kipman the
sensors flood the device with terabytes
of data every second so that's a lot
right so how's this actually going to be
managed on a device a lot of people out
there will be like well it's going to be
connected to a PC obviously to process
all that but no as I've been saying in
my videos in the past few years silicon
technology in mobile devices has come up
by orders of magnitude so now for the
first time it's possible to process all
of this in a mobile form factor now I
feel very fortunate to be in this moment
in time all the different pieces are
starting to fall into place as we enter
this decade the amount of processing
power you can get into a small form
factor for a reasonable price point is
just staggering even in the last few
years as we developed hololens the
innovation in optics sensors and silicon
has allowed us to move forward a few
orders of magnitude so the whole lens
has a CPU GPU and the first of its kind
in the world and hpu and this
fascinatingly enough is a holographic
processing unit so here's an explanation
of how it works with direct quotes from
its creator
this is kipman speaking realistic
Holograms work by tricking your brain
into seeing light as matter ultimately
you perceive the world because of light
if I could magically turn on the
debugger we would see photons bouncing
throughout the world eventually they hit
the back of your eyes and through that
you reason out what the world is you
essentially hallucinate the world or you
see what your mind wants you to see do
create project hololens images light
particles bounce around millions of
times and a light engine within the
device these photons enter the goggles
two lenses where they are ricochet
between layers of blue green and red
glass before they reach the back of your
eye and when you get the light at the
exact angle that is where the magic
comes in so translating what kipman said
unlike most screen technologies before
it is not pixels but actual photons that
are being generated making the digital
elements extremely lifelike the
resolution was really really good um you
were able to read text one of the one of
the objects in the world was a crumpled
up paper ball lebesgue newspaper you
could read the newspaper two layers down
the text was clear even from say five
feet from the virtual object so let's
let's put this at INTRUST perspective i
was able to read it from you know the
distance that i would normally read a
piece of paper but you'll recognize that
there's text oh absolutely
if I was holding it out here I was able
to read it if I was holding it right
here I was able to read it okay so this
so far sounds pretty amazing and a great
round of applause to Microsoft here and
Alex kipman but we have to take the good
with the bad what are the limitations
here okay so according to reports here
are some of the limitations currently
you can only really control hololens
with your gaze and by hovering your
finger in the air to tap on a cursor it
works fine is extremely intuitive and
everyone could get it the first time but
hololens needs more sophisticated
gestures that mimic real-life movements
the biggest limitation is the small
viewing area so really all the holograms
and the digital environments are only
visible through a small square area so
if you get close to digital objects you
can't actually see the entirety of it it
cuts them off this was one of the most
common complaints among reviewers and I
personally think that Microsoft did this
to reduce the tax on the HPU and lower
the latency so people don't feel sick
but in future generations as mobile
silicon doubles again I think we should
get over these problems okay so let's
move on to the conclusions see net sums
it up nicely according to them they stay
even in its infancy hololens gives me an
augmented reality experience that I
never knew I wanted and now I want it
again and again
conduct all my future meetings through
Highlands so how should we think of
hololens in a way much like the arrival
of oculus signaled at the infancy of
modern VR hololens
does what Google glass tried to do
kickstart the infancy of modern AR with
a player as trusted and is well
respected as Microsoft the stage is set
and we can be sure to expect some
exciting technology in the coming years
but moreover I think Microsoft is truly
back in action now anyway I hope you did
get something out of this and if you do
have a friend or someone who's wondering
about the hololens and what it all means
and just want to break down in detail of
what it actually can be like please
share this video i'm sure they'll get
something out of it if you want to see
more videos of stuff explained or about
companies or about future technology or
about alternative technology news please
subscribe anyway thanks for watching
this has been - go go you've been
watching coefficient give it a thumbs up
if you liked it and i'll catch you again
soon for the next video
cheers guys have a good one cold fusion
it's me thinking
Oh
you